robert habeck ist der beliebteste
politiker deutschlands das belegen
neueste umfragen und der grüne
vizekanzler und wirtschaftsminister ist
so etwas wie der kaiser der umfragen
doch dieser kaiser ist bald nackt denn
was kommt denn wirklich bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern an außer
mahnende oder auch mal für verständnis
werben der worte langsam das gefühl dass
wir auf dem weg in die planwirtschaft
und in die steinzeit sind ja klar es ist
schlimm dass russland unsere
energieabhängigkeit ausnutzt und sie als
waffe einsetzt und ja gewiss ist robert
habe ich nicht dafür verantwortlich dass
unsere gasspeicher nicht nicht voll sind
sondern dass sie leer waren die frage
ist aber doch was tut diese regierung
dagegen um die situation zu verändern
habe ich bei in dubai war in katar habe
ich war auch in abu dhabi und hat da
verhandelt um energie gas also das
komprimierte gas dass sie ankommen soll
ist davon irgendwas angekommen oder auf
den weg gebracht ich weiß es nicht denn
seitdem seit diesem besuch ruht still
der see und nichts haben wir gehört
seine beamten schreiben gesetz umgesetzt
aber wird dadurch irgendwas anders statt
dessen erklärungen was alles nicht geht
verlängerung der akw-laufzeiten geht
nicht aussetzen das verbot für
verbrenner ab 2035 geht nicht wer gas
umwandelt im strom soll dafür bei
strafen bezahlen ich finde wir haben
eine absolute sondersituation und
deswegen müssen auch sonder maßnahmen
ergreifen kkw laufzeiten verlängern mit
den brennstäben das kann mir keiner
erzählen dass wir die nicht weiter
bekommen das zweite ist eben jede form
von fossilen energien weiter nutzen für
diese übergangszeit steinkohle
braunkohle und vor allen dingen brauchen
wir eine positive vision für die zukunft
und nicht alles wird schlimmer oder
alles wird noch schlimmer als bei corona
sondern wir müssen sagen wie sie es
hinbekommen und uns auf den weg machen
es gemeinsam zu schaffen das wünsche ich
mir von einem vizekanzler der ja bald
auch gerne bundeskanzler werden will wer
mich freut es einerseits mich betrübt
mich freut es natürlich dass robert
habeck
wirtschaftsminister wird und du danach
für die verlängerung der atomlaufzeiten
bis
wir vor sechs monaten hier nämlich noch
gesprochen und da war das anders ja da
warte ich noch dass ich sagte du hast
doch die atommeiler länger laufen nein
das könne gar nicht sein aber das ist
doch gut dass robert haben sozusagen
alle schafft aber auf den punkt wenn du
gemacht hast er ist vollkommen richtig
robert habeck versucht die situation
auszunutzen und versucht sich nach der
gescheiterten kanzlerkandidatur von
annalena baerbock als künftiger
kanzlerkandidat jetzt schon in stellung
zu bringen hätte auch das pre bei den
grünen das ist ganz klar hat es mit
einer spd zu tun die erkennbar
schwächelt aber die große gefahr lauert
genau in dem was du geschrieben hast wie
schlimm wird der perfekte sturm den wir
jetzt sehen neuer schock also extrem
hohe inflation lieferketten problematik
krieg wenn das alles zusammenkommt dann
sehen wir an den börsen bereits es geht
dramatisch runter und wir werden einen
in eine lage kommen wenn das thema
energie so dramatisch bleibt wie es ist
dass robert habeck wirklich
möglicherweise am ende der
legislaturperiode 20 25 als der minister
da steht der den leuten verkaufen muss
warum sie eigentlich deutlich an
wohlstand verloren haben und trotzdem
glücklich sein soll und wenn da geht ist
die economy stupid dann wird robert
habeck ein veritables problem bekommt
das tut er ja schon im voraus in der
versicherungswirtschaft nimmt man das
erwartet das management für heute weiß
noch keiner so richtig absolut er tut es
ja ist ja alles wird schlimmer aber was
ich auch erwartet ist wege aufzuzeigen
wie es nicht schlimmer sondern bessere
ein bundeskanzler und das ist glaube ich
dann die kernfrage zu der es kommen wird
da kann man sagen ja du hast uns ja
vorbereitet darauf dass es schlimmer
wird aber robert habeck muss die
perspektive aufzeigen und so sind wir
menschen zum glück ja gestrickt dass wir
das eigentlich immer besser haben wollen
nicht nur für uns selbst aber auch für
die kinder und kindeskinder der muss den
weg aufzeigen wie wir eigentlich zu mehr
wohlstand kommen und das geht nicht
immer in dem man den gürtel enger
schnallt sondern man muss sich vielen
anderen gürtel zu legen der andere hose
an muss irgendwas neu und anders machen
ich wage mal die prognose
als psychologe haben wir vergessen
ich bin auch diplomierter psychologe
aber das sage ich normalerweise nicht
dürfen sie auch ja sagen
wir haben
aber keinen röntgenblick ja aber nein
ich bin überzeugter vor schluss haben
doch manche wendung machen wird und er
wird über kurz oder lang bei allen
problemen wie mir brennstäben haben
zweite abend im grunde müsste man jetzt
schon anfangen die brennstäbe etwas zu
schonen im sommer das sie dann in sechs
jahren laufen dass die neuen brennstäbe
kommen und so weiter und so weiter mehr
er wird irgendwann auch mal wieder zu
einer verlängerung der noch drei laufen
denn eigentlich bei mir zuhause
ausstehen und sogar 1
willkommen
in der psychologie nennt man das einen
konvertiten alpha habe ich wirklich
schon mal gehört konnten die grünen dass
die lehrer waren jetzt gerade hat man
das gemerkt sie möchten was beibringen
das ist gut konvertiten eifer ist einer
der war mal sage ich jetzt mal
katholisch und dann ist der
protestantisch geworden und
protestantische sodann 300% ich wollte
mein chefredakteur der welt auf den traf
das gut so der war früher bei den grünen
dann ja ok ok und die grünen machen
exerzieren diesen konvertiten eifer im
moment was rüstung betrifft
ja sie haben ihren militanten
strammen pazifismus über bord geworfen
und machen wenn ich mir den wert der
hofreiter anschauen machen jetzt stramm
auf falls ja da gibt es einen einen
unterschied die anti atomkraft bewegung
war die keimzelle die dna für die grünen
und robert habeck deswegen ist es sehr
spannend hat schon vor wenigen wochen
einmal ins spiel gebracht die meiler der
akw länger laufen zu lassen da ist
sofort ein sturm der entrüstung aus der
grünen umweltministerium den
umweltministern aus einem grünen ecken
über ihn hereingebrochen und er musste
zurückziehen aber vielleicht ist er da
schon weiter als wir alle denken nur die
grünen machen da nicht mit ich bin im
übrigen nicht für eine grundsätzliche
aufhebung des ausstiegs bei den akw es
aber dafür die jetzt länger laufen so
dass um diese unglaubliche situation der
bedrohung zu zu fällen wenn das
bemerkenswert was da passiert ist was
ist gerade schon ein bisschen
angesprochen was zu beginn des krieges
in der bundesregierung passiert ist als
robert habeck ende februar sagte man
müsse jetzt auch prüfen als erkennbar
war dass beim thema gas zu problemen
kommt dass wir uns lösen müssen von
russischem gas und öl
und gesagt wir müssen das ergebnisoffen
prüfen dann kam ein sturm der entrüstung
und es dauerte gefühlt 48 stunden
vielleicht war es auch 72 und dann stand
für die bundesregierung in form von
robert habeck und der umweltministerin
steffi lemke fest dass es beim thema
kernkraft auf keinen fall aus den
verschiedensten gründen zu einer
laufzeitverlängerung kommen kann
interessant ist wenn es um
straßenbau geht wenn irgendwo eine
besondere kröte dann am straßenrand
auftaucht dann werden gutachten über
gutachten angefordert dann wird für ein
halbes jahr nicht gebaut weil es ja
diese eine kröte da am straßenrand gibt
die ganz besonders ist und dass wir
nicht so interessant hier geht es um ein
ganzes land hier geht es um drei meiler
geht es um die stromversorgung für am
ende natürlich nicht 80 millionen
deutsche aber ein teil von 80 deutschen
und für die bundesregierung in form von
harvey und paula am ende auch des
bundeskanzlers olaf scholz steht
innerhalb von wenigen tagen fest warum
man einen entscheidenden faktor aus der
stromerzeugung am ende des jahres raus
nimmt das ist einfach nur ideale und hat
nichts mit pragmatismus richtig sagen
also ich überlege im moment immer wenn
ich sehe habeck sympathiewerte die
umfragen wenn man sich vorstellen würde
ein friedrich merz oder ein mann der
union würde das machen mit qatar dieses
video also ich finde vieles doch auch
die person robert habeck sell frage ist
was würde robert habeck machen wenn
friedrich merz das gemacht das war dann
tun oder auch wie würden teile der
presse dann auch friedrich merz losgehen
wir sind will ich mal fragen wie wie ein
wolf wie empfindest du das denn ist
robert habeck ein guter typ kannst du
verstehen die sympathiewerte für ihn in
diesem land ja also nochmal darauf
gerade gehen was ich halt schwierig
findet das große ganze wird nicht
gesehen sehr an dieser grünen ideologie
festgehalten und das bereitet uns ja
gerade eine schwierige situation
um auf deine frage zurückzukommen robert
habeck privat für mich sowieso schon mal
falsche partei dementsprechend gar keine
option aber ansonsten bisher vor allem
auch bei frauen gut ankommt wird sonst
tatsächlich nicht so nachvollziehen weil
er es mir also der quatscht halt immer
uns irgendwie nicht so zittern nicht
durch und dementsprechend aber er ist in
portion intellektueller als zu ende
kandidat india hatte und was mir heute
auf einen nenner berbalk
kandidatin und wissen sie was ich
bemerkenswert findet mehr weil mehr zum
haben die können es über kurz oder lang
gut miteinander s-bahn sich doch jetzt
in schleswig holstein an obwohl ja wie
heißt du rosey günther auch andere
optionen gehabt hätte
und es bahnt sich in oder vor allem
bevölkerungsreichsten land an die
können's miteinander die zukunft heißt
schwarz grün haben sie das habe kanzler
kann das vielleicht sogar grün schwarz
möglich empfehle ich kann natürlich kann
das besser als linda buck die antwort
auf die frage
das
war es was glauben sie mir ich meine
wenn ich mir die wenn ich mir die
energiepläne so ehrbar design mögen
anschaue dann höre ich immer nur
von seiten auch der grünen das muss
klappen das muss klappen dass wir 80
prozent unseres stroms des stroms 2030
aus erneuerbaren energien bekommen 80%
wir sind jetzt bei ungefähr etwas über
40 prozent innerhalb von acht jahren
eigentlich müssen wir den anteil
verdoppeln und wenn man fragt wird das
denn klingen wie wie soll das gelingen
dann heißt es aus der ampel koalition
auch von anderen parteimitgliedern das
muss gelingen aber müssen ist das eine
können ist das andere und das ist das
was ich extrem besorgniserregend finde
dass wir dir dass ich den augen habe
hier wird gar nicht mit einem doppelten
boden gespielt sondern wir gehen raus
aus der kohle was man verstehen kann wir
gehen raus aus der kernkraft und sagen
ja das andere muss ja klappen und selbst
wenn wir dann den atomstrom aus fehlern
gemacht sich in der hand hat wird man
pragmatische in einer assistent matthias
in einer absoluten notsituation aber ich
will noch mal auf deine frage gern
zurückkommen der stil von robert habeck
auch der kommunikationsstil im grunde
nicht er nimmt die menschen insofern
finde ich das ganz gut er nimmt die
menschen mit erteilt seine besorgnisse
teilt seine bedenken bei dem video dass
du angesprochen
und das ist ganz neu in der politik war
so was ist eigentlich schwäche als cool
aber das ist neu und insofern ist es gut
die menschen erreicht das nimmt es mit
nur am ende sind die enten fett wie es
so schön heißt das bedeutet auch er wird
auch am ende nicht mehr an den worten
gemessen an den poetischen ergießen dort
und an der wahrhaftigkeit seiner install
videos sondern an dem was da hinten
rauskommt am endeffekt und das ist bald
der zeitpunkt der kommt wo man sagen
wird du hast die krise prophezeit aber
was tust du denn dagegen und da nur zu
sagen das muss klappen das muss klappen
reicht einfach nicht aus